pas
[Musique]
dans cette salle une personne sur dix a
reçu un jour un coup de fil ces coups de
fil qu'on reçoit un peu tôt le matin ou
un peu tard le soir et qui nous font
basculer au delà de nos certitudes la
certitude une seconde avant le coup de
fil c'est que la vie va bien c'est que
le monde des drames des accidents du
handicap c'est pour les autres ceux qui
ont pas de peau et une seconde après
bien on bascule pour découvrir que c'est
aussi pour soi dans notre société que
les philosophes appellent post moderne
celle où on résume le sens de la vie à
l'efficacité et la performance
le savoir la voir le vouloir le pouvoir
le paraître aussi avec les réseaux
sociaux
le défi est majeur le défi majeur parce
que les personnes qui vivent ces
accidents
quarante mille personnes chaque année en
france pour 15 mille d'entre elles c'est
des gens qui ont un accident de voiture
c'est les 15 25 ans c'est plus vite sur
les routes plus vite dans les sports de
l'extrême aussi comme si la vie était
une grande course
et puis pour les 40 ans et plus et les
accidents vasculaires cérébraux
c'est les conséquences de la vie moderne
avec le stress la sédentarité la
malbouffe et les conséquences sont les
mêmes c'est que le cerveau qui est le
poste de commandement et bien ne suis
pas alors ce choc par cet accident
vasculaire il ya ce qu'on appelle des
lésions cérébrales et ses lésions
cérébrales ont une triple peine
les personnes se réveillent après
plusieurs semaines ou plusieurs mois de
coma
quarante mille ça fait beaucoup de monde
et se réveille avec jean handicap
physique
beaucoup sont en fauteuil certains
marche en titubant
l'autre jour fabien me disais dans la
rue chaque jour deux fois trois fois on
me demande si j'ai trop bu handicap
cognitif le handicap cognitif c'est quoi
et bien c'est des dysfonctionnements sur
la parole sur la mémoire dans nos
maisons simon de cyrène beaucoup de
personnes se rappelle très bien qu'ils
étaient avant l'accident
ils ont du mal à se rappeler de ce
qu'ils ont fait il ya deux heures ils
ont du mal à parler dans une société de
la parole c'est compliqué et puis
peut-être le plus compliqué c'est le
handicap psychique la psyché celam qui
suis-je
qui est l'autre qu'est notre société
quel est le sens de ma vie et puis
peut-être derrière ça une question
fondamentale qui vient tous nous
interpeller c'est la question du qui est
l'être humain sa veste étonnant parce
que on dit qu'il ya eu 130 milliards
d'êtres humains sur terre
les 120 milliards précédent il avait une
réalité qui était éminemment locales
pour l'essentiel d'entre eux un réalité
de son village on dépassait à 10 km déjà
une aventure
aujourd'hui on est dans un village monde
où on est relié par le truchement des
réseaux sociaux de l'information on est
relié à l'autre aux 7 milliards d'autres
le temps d'un clic et là se pose une
question fondamentale c'est la question
du qui est l'être humain
et vous et cette question du qui l être
humain elle vient mettre notre société
en tension lien nous et ce l'est l'autre
est tellement différent l'hôte est
tellement proche et tellement différent
est-ce qu'il n'est pas un risque pour ce
qui n'est pas un danger et on voit je
fais partie de la génération qui a vu
jeunes adultes le mur de berlin
s'écroulait
rappelez vous à la fin on disait fin à
l'époque on disait fin de l'histoire et
aujourd'hui je lisais récemment on n'a
jamais construit autant de murs
qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi est ce qu'on
construit des murs
parce que le grand défi civilisationnel
auquel nous sommes tous confrontés nous
mais surtout nos enfants c'est la
question de qui est l'homme qui est
l'autre qui suis-je
et tant qu'on ne répond pas à cette
question eh bien il ya une menace
majeure
c'est la menace de ma propre peur la
peur de ne pas être capable d'affronter
l'autre parce que si je ne sais pas qui
il est si je ne sais pas qui je suis
alors il ya danger
alors on est tenté cours sur des murs on
les voit se construire géopolitiquement
mais peut-être aussi des murs à
l'intérieur de soi même comme se
protéger se prémunir hélas la personne
qui se réveille après ces longs mois de
coma je vous disais quarante mille
personnes
c'est un chiffre assez récent c'est dû à
l'implantation des samu dans les années
80 cette implantation des samuel est
fascinante
arrêtons-nous de seconde elle est
fascinante pourquoi elle est fascinante
parce que en implantant les samu notre
société fait le choix politique
scientifique humain économique de dire
ta vie vaut la peine d'être vécue
même lorsque tu es gravement accidenté
ça vaut tellement la peine que j'ai
peut-être vécu que je vais mettre
quotidiennement des milliers de
personnes en veille
ça coûte des milliards chaque année à
notre pays à nos impôts je vais mettre
quotidiennement des milliers de
personnes en veille pour que si je
reçois un coup de fil pour dire que tu
as un accident vasculaire cérébral tue
un trauma crânien
dans les dix minutes un camion de
pompier voir un hélicoptère va arriver
de garder en vie est amené au samu
s'ensuit des semaines ou des mois de
coma les samu sont implantés dans les
années 80 ça veut dire quarante mille
personnes par trente ans un million deux
cent mille personnes puis son entourage
immédiat
six millions de personnes 10% des
français une personne sur dix dans cette
salle et la question est latente
la question est la tante pourquoi est-ce
qu'on garde en vie on est en droit de se
la poser
la première personne qui cela pose c'est
celle qui se réveille avec son handicap
et qui a été jusqu'à 17 ans jusqu'à 48
ans olivier 48 ans docteur en physique
nucléaire
patron d'une filiale d'un grand groupe
industriel papa de deux enfants accident
vasculaire cérébral explosion de la
cellule
familiale solitude perte de mémoire
déshérence sociale le filet est bien
fragile et nous renvoie à tout ces défis
auxquels nous sommes confrontés comme si
nous rappelait que dans une société qui
nous dit que notre
le sens de notre vie notre vie réussie
ça sera la performance et la rentabilité
et le savoir et d'avoir et bien olivier
les autres viennent nous rappeler que on
le sait avec nos enfants les 25
premières années de notre vie sont
fragiles on le sait avec nos aînés les
15-20 dernières années de la vie sont
fragiles
ça fait déjà 40 50 ans de fragilité et
les trente ans au milieu une rupture
affective sur 2 7 millions de personnes
handicapées 10 millions de mal-logés 8
millions de chômeurs ou d'emplois
précaires
est-ce qu'il n'est pas tant que la
société se réconcilie avec la fragilité
est alors lorsqu'on des comme ça emmené
avec ce coup de fil que nos certitudes
explose eh bien on entend à son réveil
la personne handicapée ne vire mais
pourquoi
en deux mots pourquoi est ce que tu m'as
garder en vie pourquoi est ce que la
société fait le choix de me garder en
vie pour quel sens
pour quelles raisons à ce qu'on garde en
vie si tu me garde en vie c'est ce que
j'entends dans les groupes de paroles
j'en avais encore un tout à l'heure
c'est une garde en vie pour que je sois
un objet de prise en charge et qu'on me
mette en marche de la société
il faut mieux me débrancher qu'on peut
entendre dans la bouche des personnes
âgées aussi est là et bien il ya comme
une bascule prophétique
vous savez qu'il prophète dans notre
société bruyante le prophète c'est celui
qui est capable de crier à la société là
où la dignité humaine est bafouée et
cette parole prophétique c'est celle de
la personne la plus fragile qui se
réveille et qui nous dit pourquoi et sa
deuxième demande
c'est une demande d'une puissance
incroyable c'est une révolution
planétaire
c'est lorsqu'elle nous dit j'ai besoin
de toi et tout d'un coup dans cette
personne fragile qui me dit j'ai besoin
de toi
elle vient de révéler que moi qui ai
peur moi qui construit des murs moi qui
ai peur d'une quête éligibles de ducey
cette performance un jour d'être mise en
marche parce que je vais moins vite
cette personne là
10 mais pas peur - se fait moins vite
j'ai besoin de toi
j'ai confiance en toi tu es capable de
moi je suis capable de toi et là on
vient découvrir une fantastique
promesses c'est que cette valeur
citoyenne de la fraternité qui nous est
si cher en france
c'est une valeur qui lorsqu'on est dans
une société qui berne un totalitarisme
sur la performance une valeur qui nous
emmène vers le fratricide
si on n'est que dans la performance tu
es un danger pour moi
l'autre est un danger pour moi dans une
société qui a été éduqué ou depuis le
carnet de notes de l'enfance on nous dit
faut être premier de classe ce risque
fratricide est majeur lorsqu'on écoute
la parole de cette personne fragile le
handicap pour simon de cyrène les
personnes âgées pour d'autres excès qui
nous dit j'ai besoin de toi
eh bien elle vient me donner l'audace de
la relation l'audace de l'altérité
l'altérité c'est l'autre le goût de
l'autre être capable de l'autre entendre
l'autre me dire ensemble on peut aller
plus loin et c'est ce qu'a fait germyn
et ce projet des maisons partager simon
de cyrène maison partagée qui ont été
médiatisés parce que notre président
d'honneur philippe pozzo di borgo de
film intouchables a fait rêver la france
pourquoi est-ce qu'on arrivait avec ce
film mais on a rêvé pas ce qui s'y passe
ce qui se passe dans nos maisons
partager des hommes et des femmes
valides handicapés avec des handicaps
sociaux physique ou autres qui
lorsqu'ils n'ont plus peur de l'autre
plus peur de la fragilité plus peur de
la différence découvre que conjuguer nos
différences c'est faire jaillir la vie
c'est faire jaillir l'audace c'est faire
jaillir d'ajoie sévère jaillit de goût
de vivre et finalement est ce que ce
goût de l'autre c'est pas dans nos vies
pressé ce qui reste dans le tamis à la
fin de la journée
peut-être à la fin de nos vies ce qui
reste c'est ce que s'est passé c'est
tous ces moments on a osé cette relation
confiance à l'autre est ce que c'est
parce qu'elle du bout et ce qui nous
fait du bien
alors on a réuni un certain nombre de
personnes handicapées et valides des
gens qui sont devenus amis parce qu'ils
étaient à l'hôpital après cet accident
et puis je les ai écoutés
on les a écoutés nous dire mais vous
savez moi depuis que je suis handicapé
ma plus grande souffrance c'est par le
handicap la plus grande souffrance et la
solitude dans une société qui va vite
la solitude c'est le grand défi de
chacun de nous lorsqu'on devient un peu
plus fragiles un peu plus lent que les
autres
on est tous en situation de risque c'est
la bonne nouvelle on est tous concernés
on va tous âges ou être capable de dire
à l'autre j'ai besoin de toi fantastique
ce souffle là ce souffle la savez c'est
pas si vieux dans les années 30
quelqu'un disait il ya des races
supérieures et des races inférieures qui
disait ça on envie de dire hitler pas du
tout c'est un des plus grands humanistes
winston churchill vous rendez compte
l'incroyable évolution de la conscience
de l'être humain
qu'est-ce qu'il a fallu se passe et pour
ça il a fallu que dix ans plus tard
cette conscience là arrivent à permettre
les camps de la mort
hiroshima l'autre différent mérite
d'être exterminés et à ce moment-là
sursaut de conscience de l'humanité en
1948 choix universel de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
l'égalité des êtres humains
trente ans plus tard un homme a eu un
écho prophétique dans son premier cri de
pape jean paul ii lorsqu'il a dit
partout la dignité humaine est bafouée
nous devons nous sentir concernés quel
fantastique appel pour la mondialisation
va être concerné par tout la dignité
mais n'est pas fou et et trente ans plus
tard l'homme le plus puissant du monde
est noir mais ce n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire parce qu'on voit combien les
risques des replis identitaires combien
ce que le risque de remettre des murs
revient vite
est-ce qu'il n'appartient pas à chacun
nous d'entendre la parole de celui qui
nous dit j'ai besoin de toi et nos
groupes simon de cyrène nest ces petits
groupes d'amitié où on découvre tout
simplement que ça nous fait du bien on
entend l'autre dire ma souffrance et la
solitude puis sous les handicaps et où
on a envie ensemble de se retrouver pour
tout simplement animée dans les villes
des temps informel des temps d'amitié
des tables d'hôtes
on ne sait pas qui ça n'a plus aucune
importance on se laisse appeler j'ai
besoin de toi ça me fait du bien ça du
goût
et on revit une petite scène
d'intouchable samedi après samedi
journée après journée
aujourd'hui on a douze associations en
france près de 2000 personnes qui goûte
comme c'est bon de se laisser appelé par
son prénom en savoir combien notre vie a
du sens
lorsqu on s'ouvre à l'altérité et de ça
et bien on a un jour osé ensemble rêver
quitté l'institution médico social qui
est tellement nécessaire mais que l'on a
envie de quitter parce qu'on n'est pas
chez soi
et aujourd'hui tous les professionnels
accompagnent ce mouvement là et
lorsqu'on arrive à domicile est bien là
les personnes nous disent je crève de
solitude
manu me disait chez elle c'est grand
c'est beau mais moi seule et elle a
fondu en larmes et là et bien en fait
ont créé ces maisons c'est du logement
social est en fait cohabiter des
personnes handicapées et des personnes
valides
chacun à son studio un peu comme une
espèce de grandes maisons d'hôtes ya un
couple d'autres et puis un grand salon
salle à manger cuisine et dans ceux dans
ces lieux là cohabitent des personnes
handicapées des jeunes aux ventes à un
service civique
l'autre jour geoffrey me disais ça
faisait des années que je me cherchais
un jeune de 19 ans ici je me suis
trouvée et lui répondait il cédric dans
son fauteuil roulant qui disait ici je
suis un vivant extraordinaire de pouvoir
faire jaillir ces lieux de société où
chacun de nous handicaper fragiles âgées
va pouvoir dire je suis un vivant et ce
projet a été valorisé parce qu'il a été
lauréat du prix la france s'engage de
l'elysée ce qui nous a valu la première
visite du premier ministre dans une de
nos maisons au mois de mai qu'est venue
passer deux heures en disant il faut des
maisons partout comme ça en france
même à lorient et lorsque fabien était
invité à l'élysée peut on a été ensemble
recevoir ce prix élevé les dix ministres
il y avait les 500 personnes c'est
encore plus impressionnant aujourd'hui
et il a eu cette parole extraordinaire
il a regardé tout le monde
il a dit je vais vous dire une réponse à
une question vous n'osez pas posée vous
n'osez pas me demander quel est mon
handicap à mon handicap
c'est je suis
mais vous savez la lenteur c'est pas
toujours un handicap lorsque je me
promène je marche lentement mais lorsque
je suis avec un ami la promenade dure
plus longtemps
et lorsqu'on mange dans nos maisons
partager simon sirène avec nos amis je
mange lentement mais la fête dure plus
longtemps
et lorsque je parle je parle long mais
vous n'écoutez mieux alors fabien merci
à toi pour ton la parole prophétique et
j'ai envie de m'en faire écho j'ai envie
nous inviter à réfléchir chacun pour me
dire finalement comment ce que chacun
plutôt que de dénoncer une société qui
va trop vite qui est inhumaine
comment ce que chacun dans ses talents
dans ses compétences là où la ville
appelle avant chaque année nous devenir
acteur d'une société plus fraternelle
[Musique]
mais